so what is quit quit as a new app where
you can collect exclusive digital
sticker cards and toys for free
featuring all the shows you like such as
Breaking Bad Adventure Time Star Trek
and most importantly Game of Thrones
this app has a lot of Game of Thrones
collectibles and the best thing about it
is if you're a person who likes ending
emojis and stickers with this app you
can put the Ned Stark Daenerys Targaryen
or Tyrion Lannister stickers their text
or you can also collect cards they made
a pretty fun game of collecting them til
you open up packs of stickers and cards
and it kinda brings me to the days of
opening football cards as a kid so when
you get the app make sure you add me as
a friend my username is fire and blood
and if I have something you're not able
to unlock we can make trades together
and there's also chat for Game of
Thrones community so we can trade with
other people who use Game of Thrones
stickers you can also showcase your
collection by adding stickers to
anything on your camera roll link and my
username will be down below in the
description so feel free to check it out
it's available for iOS and Android but
it's not as smooth on Android yet since
it's still in beta and also quick
sidenote new stickers cards and figures
that you can collect for free or release
everyday if your Game of Thrones nerd
just like I am then you're really gonna
love this app and the best thing about
it is it's free use the link in the
description and give it a try and don't
forget to add me as a friend hey guys
preview for the sixth episode just
dropped and it pretty much confirms a
few main events that we're about to see
in the next episode so it out further do
let's just jump into it it starts with
the excursion beyond the wall which
includes John ginjury Thoreau's Barrack
Jorah Tommen the Hound and a few unknown
soldiers those shots are accompanied
with barracks saying death is the enemy
the first enemy in the last the
excursion continues to the north trying
to follow the vision the hound saw in
the flames which is when they finally
see the mountain shaped like an
arrowhead meanwhile turnin whatin says
how much the NER starts to care about
John and is an interesting in anything
but news of John Barry continues can
sentence by saying the enemy always
Vince and we still need to fight him
this is when a large Blizzard starts and
John and his team are being attacked by
a horde of whites they basically running
for the army of the Dead led by one
white Walker that looks like the one
John killed previously that is when John
barrels his second white Walker
one-on-one and
battles him the others try to capture
white but it's hard as the other whites
also attack them at the same time at
this point white army attacks all at
once without mercy which is when John
and his team see that the only thing
they can do is run the group that
decides they must split for a little bit
as they run to raise a chance of
survival after they run for a while they
come together in the middle of a frozen
lake when supposedly all the movement
and fighting eventually breaks up parts
of Weiss and John and his team are stuck
in the middle of a lake on a large piece
of ice that floats above the other
smaller pieces of ice John and his team
can't do anything but to basically wait
for the lake to freeze and for the army
of the Dead to attack them during this
time awaiting the night king lurks
around and from afar stares at John and
John stares back with out of fear the
lake has finally frozen and the Horde
rushes at John and his team they run but
end up fighting considering that this is
a video in which I'm breaking down the
preview for the upcoming episode I
decided not to cover any major spoiler
for this same episode that is not either
hinted or confirmed by this preview if
you would like to know more details
about this huge fight feel free to check
out our video of mine by the name season
7 episode 6 sleek scenes in that very
among all other events I also covered
the whole fight in which the current
best warriors in the Seven Kingdoms will
face of the White Walkers in their army
of the Dead a fight in which some major
deaths and the resurrections will take
place anyways there are also a few shots
from interval or he brings the letter
she found in Littlefinger's room and
confronts sense of a that same letter
sensor had made the sign back in the
very first season there are some rumors
that sensible wonder water has been
doing the whole time she's been gone and
we'll do some sneaking around and find
all phases and poisons sorry Owens
Sansa finding all of this and re on the
other hand entering the same room at the
same time with perfectly faith
Vittorio's line in which she's saying
you're scared aren't you what are you
scared of